hello and good afternoon welcome to
today's commonwealth club program my
name is debra j saunders and i'm pleased
to be the moderator for today's program
i'm a fellow with the discovery
institute's chapman center for citizen
leadership and i'm a syndicated
columnist you may have seen me
previously on the club's week-to-week
program which focuses on top news and
current events
thus i'm pleased to be here today to
discuss john mcwarner's new book woke
racism how a new religion has betrayed
black america it came out last week and
it is already making waves and inspiring
debates for its insightful critiques of
critical race theory and anti-racism
john's now a regular columnist for the
new york times and the author of several
books on linguistics and he's an
associate professor at columbia
university
john welcome to the commonwealth club
for today's discussion on your new book
but one quick note before we jump in if
you have any questions for john or me
please put them on the youtube chat
feature and they'll be forwarded to
forwarded to me during the program so
john let's begin um i love the book it
never got boring and it made me think
about the world in a new way so before i
drill down tell us why did you write the
book what's it about and what do people
who really really don't like your
viewpoint say about it and how do you
respond the book is written
not
as
some
sweater vested starchy kind of person
who is writing a book that's designed to
get money from white conservatives
that's what a lot of people think about
black quote-unquote conservative
thinkers although what i am is a liberal
who just gets on people's nerves but
it's not that this is not a right wing
black book especially because i'm not of
the right wing what it's for
is really mostly people left of center
who are listening to these voices from
the radical hard left and beginning to
get a feeling that somehow those
people's view must be actual truth
rather than one facet of the left out of
fear because there's a certain kind of
person who now basically tells you that
you're a racist i.e what we now think of
as a moral pervert if you disagree with
what is actually a very narrow under
thought and punitive range of views
i think that what we need is left of
center but constructive and
unself-concerned positions on what black
people need in this country and so i
think that
what most people are going to say about
it i've been being you know beaten up on
by that kind of person for my views on
race now since late in the clinton
administration so it's old old news and
it's interesting because
you're only as good as what you did last
week and there are people these days who
i can tell i completely understand it i
think a lot of people think i first
started writing for the daily beast in
about 2015 and that right now i'm making
my way that i'm climbing up and getting
a little bit of attention they think
that i'm new at this and so i think
that's part of why they throw this at me
so hard but the main thing is that they
say that i am just writing this book
because they're the sorts of things that
white people want to hear and that's
really not true the book is written for
black people as much as for white people
i think most black people especially
once you step about two feet beyond the
intelligentsia and the media agree with
the sorts of things i'm saying and this
is the hard thing to the extent that a
certain kind of enlightened sensitive
white person
wants to hear what i've written in woke
racism they should there's a facile idea
that what white people want to hear must
automatically beat racist and letting
white people off the hook that's facile
that's simplistic it could be the
probability does allow that what a white
person enjoys hearing is also the moral
truth and i'm taking a gamble that my
book falls into that realm so that's
what woke racism is um your book it
starts out with the story of food writer
alison roman for the new york times she
criticized marie kondo and she
criticized chrissy teigen for cashing in
on commercialism and and she was
professionally destroyed for it uh
because condo is japanese and teagan's
half white and people were saying she
was a racist and she was punching down
you really don't like that phrase
punching down
uh she's she was suspended she
eventually left the new york times
and you don't think she would have been
targeted five years ago
and professionally destroyed the way she
was now can you talk about
how things change so quickly and uh if
if you see well and then i'll do a
follow-up when you're done
yeah it's interesting you bring up her
because i opened the book with her and
that
really was what sparked me to write the
book it was something that sounds that
trivial i like her i like i like the
food that she was teaching me to make
during the pandemic and all of a sudden
she was gone and i noticed it and then i
read why and that was when something
clicked in me and i thought this is
absolutely absurd and i could tell it
was going to continue and it most
certainly did i thought this is the new
mood there is a newly influential group
of people who are going to keep doing
this and i can't have it so it wasn't me
rubbing my hands together and thinking
hahahaha i'm going to write a book that
white people want to read about racism
it was where is my food columnist that
was what it really was and what that was
was that she was essentially fired for
not
trying to oh not trying to battle power
differentials there's an analysis there
the idea is that chrissy tegan is half
thai and therefore not completely white
marie kondo is a japanese citizen and
you know that's many things it's not a
white american person or a white
european person and therefore to
criticize them if you're white is some
sort of moral transgression and all of
us know except for roughly seven and a
half people who are probably responsible
for getting her fired that it makes no
sense for her to lose her job for these
offhanded criticisms of these two very
rich very influential people
neither of whom
think of themselves as
at the hands of white hegemony both of
them were perplexed at all this and yet
that's the way it had to be and i
thought wow and this is the main thing
about what i thought i thought the
people who got alice and roman fired
thought they were doing a good thing i
wasn't thinking that they're holding
pitchforks and running down a hill i
thought these are peaceable sensible
probably overeducated people who
genuinely thought that what they did was
the right thing but the thing is most of
the rest of us know that what they did
was a barbarity and i thought what is
the gap in understanding here and i
thought it's this issue of power being
everything and i took it from there
did she make a mistake apologizing
before she was suspended would if she
had if she had fought back sooner would
that have helped
you know she couldn't have known because
the history has been going by so quickly
in her time you know which was 15
minutes ago it was reasonable for her to
think that she could apologize and be
let alone but it absolutely didn't work
it only made it worse and we've all seen
things like that but all of that took a
real real jump starting in the spring of
2020. so in retrospect no
she should have said i haven't done
anything wrong you can say whatever you
want to about me and i will suffer the
consequences but i will admit no
culpability but i understand why in the
spring of 2020 she didn't know that it
had gotten so bad that people like this
needed to be standed down on moss across
the country she couldn't have known now
i'll bet she would have or if for
some reason she asked me i would tell
her don't apologize
and
by the way thank you for pronouncing
hegemony because i you said in the book
a lot of people don't know how to
pronounce it i'm like do i or don't i
now i know i appreciate that you're a
linguist
and uh
it was very
made me very insecure so are you seeing
uh
do you think things are going to get
worse or are they going to get better
are there signs that this is ending or
that people are suddenly realizing that
you're right that these people are that
nice people are actually going out and
hounding people uh trying to take away
their jobs for trivial uh faults it
what's the answer to that yeah yeah i
think it's changing
and six months ago i wasn't sure but at
this point i'm seeing various signs that
there's going to be a pushback against
this partly as we come out of the
pandemic partly as we see so much of it
happening that we realize that it's
quote unquote a thing
noticing how for better or for worse the
word woke is now a slur that happened
because this kind of person has
has
annoyed and and and bemused so very many
i hate to say normal thinking people
yeah um this is one of my books that i
can tell i shouldn't say this i would
like people to read it i can tell that
this book is going to be topical this is
going to be one which in 10 years is
going to be seen as part of a certain
moment and it was part of a push back
against something and i hope helped to
serve a purpose
i do see it changing and i wanted to do
everything that i could to make sure
that as many people as possible
understood that to resist this
particular extreme is not racist no
matter what the elect as i call them say
and no matter whether that elect person
is black it's not racist other things
are so i hope this book will be a part
of that
well and by the way you you quote jody
bottom and you take the phrase the elect
from jody bottom uh but he was talking
about religious people
and you're talking about people whose
politics have become a religion
um
i i have to tell you you've totally
radicalized me
because i i spent 24 years as a
conservative columnist for the san
francisco chronicle and i was really
tender about how i dealt with people but
you're saying and one of the things i
really got out of your book is you're
telling people don't apologize for your
viewpoints
ditch the anguish don't back down
when people start challenging you a
certain way don't try to be nice about
it give it back to them i was on twitter
like yesterday and i was thinking about
what we were going to talk about and i
just jumped on someone's throat
you've made me sort of feel that when
people when people start trying to
challenge you and make you feel like
maybe they're going to say you're a
racist that you've just got to slam him
back
yeah and you know i'm not a belligerent
person but i think that when it comes to
this type we need to simply stand up in
the same way that they're standing up
and look them in the eye and say no and
i use the analogy of bopping a shark on
the nose and i don't want people to
think that i mean you're supposed to be
physical with anybody but with this
elect kind of person and not just
anybody who's arguing from the left but
this type
who is poised to call you a moral
pervert in the public square if you
don't agree with their views you just
have to say no i am not a racist i don't
agree with what you're saying and you
can say whatever you want about me
wherever you will i am not changing my
mind if we say that enough
to the extent that we can within the
parameters of our lives to this kind of
person then this will change but it does
mean that a lot of people and
unfortunately here we're talking about
mainly white people have a
responsibility which is that not only do
you have to know that racism is more
than burning crosses on people's lawns
that was not the most natural way of
thinking for white people and i think
most white people got that message but
now the idea has to be get used to being
called a racist in social media realize
that the world will keep spinning your
life in most cases will keep going
but in the meantime you can't give these
people what they want because if you
give it to them they'll take it and if
you really want a world run by people
who have taken what is supposed to be a
kind of compassion into a social justice
religion it's not about fairness but
about virtue signaling if you don't want
that world these people have to be told
to sit back down not to leave the room
but just to sit back down and what i
really hope is that people have that
backbone and they must understand this i
am not telling white people to tell
black people to sit down my main mental
image is it's a white person who you're
telling to sit down although there are
certainly black people like this
although it's not the way most black
people think that's something i wish
more people would keep in mind
yeah you you make that really clear in
the book i mean one of the things that
you write about is you say that uh
basically the elect
uh they they they
they seem to they they
think as if black people are hot house
flowers who will be who will wilt under
certain kinds of uh criticism and so
that every anything that you see that
might be dysfunctional behavior among
certain individuals is something that
you have to
uh coach in incredibly sensitive ways uh
and in what you say is what basically
you've seen people do is lower their
standards in order to seem nicer and
and not racist can you talk about that
for a minute please
yeah i reject the idea that to be a
black person
is to walk around in a constant
existential kind of pain because of
things that happened hundreds of years
ago or things that happened 50 years ago
or even a terrible murder of a black man
two years ago there's this idea that
every black individual walks around
carrying the entire history of the race
upon them and that therefore you have to
be very sensitive when you talk about
race issues around us and that you have
to basically come as close as you can to
giving in to any demand that any of us
make and it follows naturally from that
that you give black people a pass you
cannot expect serious competition to be
engaged in by such a person who's so
burdened a little but essentially what
would be a consolation prize to other
people is supposed to be the top prize
for us
i reject that and i don't reject that as
somebody who is uniquely rock ribbed i
don't reject that because i didn't grow
up poor i reject that because i think
it's a natural way of thinking which
black people in the past
generally had there was no push from the
intelligentsia and the media to adopt
yes i can't as a mantra and just last
week condoleezza rice was on the view
expressing exactly the views that i'm
expressing and she grew up in the
segregated south there's nothing unique
about where she came from in that way
she titled her autobiography
extraordinary ordinary people who told
her this and this is she grew up in
birmingham of all places and i don't
mean in england in alabama where hideous
things were happening to black people in
the street she knew the four little
girls who were killed in the church
there and yet she knew
that yes we can't
is not progress
that was an idea that settled in in the
late 60s in certain circles and that
notion was really magnified and sent out
to mainstream america in the wake
of george floyd's murder in particular i
reject it and i reject it thinking of
myself as utterly ordinary in that i
want people to you know i want people to
put on the patch the mental patch of
thinking when somebody
says they're gonna call me a racist on
twitter look them in the eye and call
them a racist fat that's that's weird
i'm using that word patch because people
use it in linguistics and i shouldn't
but i want people to get rid of that
little weird blip in thinking that
they've been taught that black people
are weak that black people can't be
subject to real standards because of
slavery and jim crow and redlining i
don't think our ancestors wanted us to
think of it that way
so one of the reasons your book woke
racism how a new religion has betrayed
black america
uh one of your points is that
when you have so many people uh in the
elect and we'll get into what the elect
is in a second thinking that the
important thing is what how they feel
about other people and think about other
people
not looking for practical things
solutions about disparity that that
deserves that that's a disservice to
everybody in this country um and uh can
you can you talk to that for a second
please
sure it's really very simple
a lot of the people that we're talking
about are under the impression that
showing that you understand that
societal racism exists
is really key
they think that
showing that you understand that is a
necessary prelude to changing the world
and the problem is
says who
in in what sense where did you get that
nobody would have had any idea what that
meant 60 years ago in the civil rights
movement so what's the proof now and i
imagine some very sophisticated
political science or sociology
professors have answers and you know
maybe some academic journals that
nobody's ever read or some books that i
haven't gotten to but the point hasn't
been made in any mainstream way that we
can say that all of those people who are
pretending this know
it's just that it feels right frankly
it's easy so you stand up and show that
you know something and everybody does
high fives but what have you done for
somebody who's suffering no one really
asks that question except
someone like robin deangelo in
literally the worst book ever written
it's the worst book i've ever read and
if there's one thing that i have done a
lot of it's read books worst book ever
written she actually says she actually
anticipates this question that if you're
asking okay but what are you actually
gonna go do it's called solutionism
you're going too fast you're letting
yourself off the hook because what
you're really supposed to think about is
how you're complicit in a racist system
but someone like me standing on the
outside asks why how is this better than
what happened before and the thing is if
somebody can give an answer
you can't give the answer with the
attitude of well of course it's because
no one has said what it was we're having
a whole
national discussion where nobody
explains that despite the fact that it's
a painfully obvious question so
my book in part is designed to ask it
and to show that frankly there is no
answer
so i want to get to questions from uh
viewers but i have just one area i want
to go over with you first you said the
the most
effective way to help uh
black people poor black people in
america is to do three things end the
war on drugs
teach phonics and offer more vocational
training
you don't mention family
so
no
so i i i was surprised
but obvi and obviously you think it's
really obvious so explain to me
very i'm sorry if i see you
there
i know many people who um have written
very
compelling pieces about
family values and the value of there
being two parents in the home
um i certainly know what the expansion
of welfare in the late 60s did to black
communities it's a little told story
i have now and then said i wish somebody
would make a movie about that because it
would get it into the consciousness of
what that did but in general my feeling
is
to write about the family to write this
is what people should do more people
should get married more men should stay
in relationships that they maybe don't
want to be in
i don't see
how effective that would be that's all
it's not that i don't agree there's the
wonderful statistic that you know if you
graduate from high school and you get a
job and you know you don't have a child
until you're married or at least you
know permanently involved you will not
be poor yeah that's true but in terms of
saying to people out in the world that
it seems to me that people have been
saying that that you can date it to
roughly you could date it to the
moynihan report but there have been
things being written since about the mid
80s
and what i'm interested in is results
and it doesn't seem to work you can't
tell people to have different family
values it seems to me that those values
will fall out of other policy decisions
that will shape the world around people
that's my feeling and that's why there
was nothing about i'll bet single
parenthood is not in the book i never
wrote i didn't write that and that's why
you had one teensy teensy mention
because i was listening for looking for
it but you know one of the things i mean
ending the war on drugs that's a great
idea too but how realistic is that i
mean there have been people who've been
writing about that for a long time hey
it's even hard to get schools to use to
teach phonics
i mean that's not even easy and more
vocational training same thing i mean
the last two things they're less
controversial but it's hard to get them
through and in the war on drugs i just
don't
um and i know that i know that you want
to get in the complete war on drugs
which just doesn't seem all that
realistic either or am i wrong is there
some place that's starting to do that
really legitimate questions and i
include them because
over the past 20 years and 20 is not 50.
i haven't been around that long but over
the past 20 years i've seen cracks in
the plaster on those things and so the
fact that
to be graphic nowadays you can walk down
new york streets and smell marijuana
right up your nose and there's somebody
just standing right there to be honest i
think that that's fine you know if you
can drink bourbon why should you not be
able to marijuana that's the beginning
and i know an awful lot of people who
have agitated for it to go further
including i don't have time these days
because i'm a dad even some branches of
the naacp
were opening up to that idea despite the
fact that in most of those cases you're
dealing with conservative ministers
where that's not where they live but
they were beginning to open up to it so
i thought it's not
impossible but deborah you're right
that's that that's a tough one with
vocational education
we're seeing some interest in that sort
of thing going back to the obama
administration i think that could be
made to float phonics is a whole other
story but yeah i take your point
okay uh
from viewers uh first question
critical race theory uh seems to exploit
the power of words to tongue-tie
everyone including me
how do you counteract such deliberate
attempts to redefine common words
you know you can't
counteract
people's
reformation
of words it's inevitable in
language change it's almost never
deliberate but unfortunately with
critical race theory our discussion is
polluted by the fact that there are
certain legal papers written decades ago
that you know nobody but a legal scholar
could love
and then there's that way of thinking
having percolated into
graduate schools and humanities and
social sciences and also education
schools
such that philosophies based on those
ideas
are now being promulgated and fostered
upon eight and nine year olds and so
someone says what is critical race
theory doing in our classrooms and the
smart response is supposedly to say
who's teaching these obscure legal
scholars in class when that's obviously
not what anybody needs i think that at
this point it's maybe handy that what's
happening in the classes might be called
crt and that we all know what that's an
abbreviation for but that little i've
written a few columns trying to cut
through that
so i've done a podcast about it but i
podcast episode about it my lexicon
valley which i'm not trying to push but
i've never written out a full column
about only that but i did do a lexicon
valley about what crt means you can't
help that but what disamazed me the most
actually on this day that we're doing
this i'm realizing this is a thing
is that
a lot of people left of center really
don't think that there's anything going
on in classrooms they think that we
should be talking about january 6th and
and we should but there's there's no
problem with anything going on in our
schools whatever you call it and the
people like me are just making that up
based on having read maybe one story
about one school i think there is in us
who know that that's not true and i'm
thinking we need to
we need to craft that message better
because a lot of really smart
well-intentioned people think that we're
just making things up because that's
what a certain kind of person tells them
and they understandably listen to them
so there's a messaging issue but
language will always change terms will
always be messy we just have to analyze
what the mess is which is where
my work is beginning to intersect but my
work is beginning to straddle
linguistics and race more than it ever
has because i'm beginning to have to use
both halves of my brain lately because
yeah the way we talk about these things
often is because of how annoying the
change of meaning and words can be
because it could happen so quickly
so
today i'm i am in virginia as we speak
and it is election day
nothing going on down there
yeah
derrick democrat tara mcauliffe says
that they don't teach crt in public
schools
he's wrong and you know and if he means
they don't teach the the works of
richard delgado and kimberly crenshaw
he's right
but if he means that all the parents and
friends who write me saying guess what
sorts of things my child's history
teacher is teaching and i wrote the
principle and the principal wrote me
back something in hebrew that doesn't
make any sense and won't listen that's
happening across the country it doesn't
have to be critical race theory itself
but if your kids are being taught that
whiteness is a kind of inherent guilt if
your kids are being taught that
blackness is a kind of eternal
victimhood if your kids are being taught
that all subjects need to be looked at
through the lens of what they signal for
power relations especially between white
and brown people that's what your kids
are being taught to any appreciable
extent such that they would come home
and say i'm not enjoying this mom that's
critical race theory and
anybody who denies that that's an issue
either doesn't know and you know some
people find education policy boring you
know i don't care about football i don't
know anything about it there are many
people who live for football i get it
maybe you don't care about education or
you're being willfully
naive because you're trying to placate a
certain base and get elected and i would
completely understand that too but that
means that we can't listen to that fight
between those two for a reflection of
what's actually happening either way yes
there is something really scary going on
in education today
so i have another question uh john what
do you think of the 1619 project
um
the truth about it is that a lot of it
is just a history lesson and it's a
history lesson that you know [ __ ] our
ear more to power differentials than we
might be used to but there's nothing
wrong with it
what got it a pulitzer
was the claim that the revolutionary war
was fought to a significant degree
because of people not wanting to let go
of slavery the idea being that to to to
lose the war would mean that you could
not have
plantations it would seem to me that
that claim has been disproven
and that's what i think of the 1619
project any discussion of it that
purports that a central and highly
celebrated tenet of it was not disproven
is
a discussion that i have a hard time
participating in i'll put it i'll put it
that way
there are a lot of things you have
that you just have lost patience for
these prevalent beliefs that go against
what you have what you understand as an
academic um and let me you teach at
columbia uh
what are your students like these days
do you think they're prepared
uh you've been teaching for a while are
they better prepared now are they
um
are they are they up to the challenges
are
how how how prepared do you think they
are for university education
you know deborah i don't know the answer
to that question yet
because um of mundane things which is
that
everything went crazy in the spring of
2020 but by then universities were
online and that puts a real filter
between you and students i don't i don't
get to talk to them offline much and so
i just have taught them in classes and
now we're just now back on campus and
you know honestly with everybody in
masks which they are at columbia it
muffles communication and experience
once again and
i hate to say this it's not that i'm an
anti-massacre or an anti-vaxxer or
anything but having to always have that
thing on my face means that i avoid
being on campus because i want to
breathe and smell the world so i'm not
really back on campus yet except to sit
in rooms with cloth on my face and it's
not the same so i don't know that's a
question i'll have more of a sense of in
the spring
when i'll be spending more time on
campus and something will be able to
happen outside and so you're not always
talking through this curtain and i know
that sounds trivial but it really does
affect how how you smell a campus how
you get a sense of what's going on now
if you had asked me before the pandemic
i would have said that
the idea that the campus is being taken
over by tenured radicals i've always
thought that was vastly exaggerated
until roughly june of 2020 when suddenly
all of that hysteria from 1997 came true
which is why i started getting up on a
soapbox so that's my real view i used to
say my students don't act like that i
said that for years and years and
colombia has been almost oddly immune to
the sorts of scenes that you've seen at
yale for example that that simply hasn't
happened around me i don't know those
kids has something happened since then
i'm inclined not to think so but i just
can't say anything yet because i can't
report from the ground
you know one of the things i'm thinking
as i'm reading this book is uh one of
the messages is they can go after anyone
for for the most inconsequential thing
uh do you have a plan i mean it's i'm
guessing that no one do you have a plan
if
obviously you're still there you're
still the new york times you're still at
columbia you're still doing things
have you has anyone ever gone after you
and how did you deal with it or if if it
hasn't happened how what how will you
um that's a good question i should say
that that has not happened at columbia
yet i have gotten no signals of that
kind from any of the higher-ups however
i would be an idiot not to wonder
whether it could happen because you
never know and all it would take is one
person who decides to interpret one
thing that i write or say
and it would snowball and i
i have no reason to think that if it
snowballed beyond a certain point that i
could not be
be
let go yes that that could happen and so
i've spent a lot of time since the
middle of 2020 because i'm not going to
stop i'm not going to back down i had
spent a lot of time
setting things up
so that i would continue to be able to
pay my mortgage and continue to be able
to make a living
and i've done that that job is complete
and so i'm not that worried my sense is
watch this comment you know bite me on
the quote unquote elbow in a couple
years my sense is
that i'm not going to lose my job for
one thing the pendulum is shifting and
there's some other factors it would be a
pretty bad look to fire me for those
things
but if it does happen
i will land on my feet and i will
continue to say things so that's the
idea i realize i cannot let
that possibility keep me from having my
say because i think that that said that
say needs to be had and i hope that some
other black professors will follow me
and from what i'm seeing that's gonna
happen
and so yeah
that's that's how that is you know
another thing deborah is that um
i get the feeling that if they were
thinking of doing that i'm 56. well one
pragmatic discussion might be well how
long is he going to hang in anyway i'm
not sure they know that i i'm going to
keep doing this into my 80s if i can but
they might think well just let him do it
for another seven or eight years so yes
i've thought about it but i have not
seen any portent of it yet
well i'm glad to hear that um
jody bottom is a friend of mine and you
mentioned in your book so please talk
about the elect for a second and why
and why you decided to use that term in
your book as well
since joe um thank you to jody because
jody it's the title you know the titles
of my books are never
the ones that i originally had and all
of my materials for the book woke racism
on my laptop now the label the book is
called the elect and that's a part of me
that will always call it that the elect
is um
my name for these people where it isn't
that they're speaking why is my voice
cracking like i'm henry aldrich it isn't
that they are seeking power
it isn't that they're mean
it isn't that they're children it's
important to realize the elect is not
about college campuses the elect can be
in their 70s
these are people
who feel that they have a good news with
a capital g and a capital n
that the world needs to listen to and
that this is news that is so
incontestably good
that it's worth hurting people in order
to
make things so that the world works
according to these tenets but the way
they conduct themselves and their utter
imperviousness to any kind of logic or
or reason is reminiscent of people who
think of themselves as chosen and these
are people who do think of themselves as
having a precious higher wisdom that
they feel is so precious that they will
impose it upon the world via whatever
means necessary and you make the point
of saying the the worst thing about this
phenomenon is they're not mean people
these are people who think they're nice
good people and that they're doing the
right thing when they go after somebody
like that um one of the things that you
that you had mentioned earlier and it's
also in the book the elect scare you
more than january 6.
could you talk about that for a second
please
yeah yeah um
you have to ask about institutions what
institutions are people like that
penetrating
and the snappy answer these days is that
those people are overturning
voting laws and that they're they're
trying to get black people not to vote
and i understand where that's coming
from but i can't help noticing that on
the ground
once you get past the symbolism it is
revolting that somebody tries to
suppress the black vote in order to keep
democrats from having too high a tally
it's revolting on many levels but it
doesn't work as well as we're often told
that's the thing that i think the left
doesn't want to admit it's a terrible
gesture from the right but it doesn't
actually work that well and in the
meantime what i see happening
with the elect is that they're taking
over
academia
the media the arts
and the law
they're taking over all four of those
things and there's a certain kind of
person that will tell me
that those things aren't as important
as
people trying to keep black people from
voting and failing well you know what
that makes no sense to me and i think
that makes no sense to a lot of people
to ask why it's a big deal that a
certain group of people
are deeply affecting the way we teach
learn question
judge and think and paint and make music
that's what these people are doing to
say that's no big deal is frankly
philistine and i don't think most people
who ask that question really believe
that it's a it's a valid point this is
huge these people are taking over
institutions and we have to stop them or
we don't live
in what we lived in before and notice
i'm not about to say something about
america i'm not that corny this is not
about some sort of jingoism just what we
had most of us aren't running around
thinking about ourselves as americans
just what we had as modern enlightened
people i will not watch that turned over
by people who think that treating me
like a child and
then doing high fives over the fact that
you did it and it shows that you know
racism exists because george floyd died
unjustly
no
that is not the way social history is
supposed to proceed i won't allow it and
that's why i wrote woke razo
so
you talk about january 6 as being an
effort to
suppress the black
vote that i mean i thought that was
people who thought
wrongly that trump had won and that's
why they went to the capitol
are you sort of
conflating what happened then with
what's happened afterward or
am i missing something
no no i'm i'm trying to give the people
who say this the benefit of the doubt
the idea is that the people who think
that trump really should have won the
election they think that trump won the
election and that therefore procedures
needed to be overturned in order to make
it look that way
are the same people who are interested
in overturning basic voting procedure
and making sure that black people don't
vote much kind of a stretch but the idea
being people who want to interfere
with the electoral mechanisms in order
to have things their own way and then
there's a kind of a sloppy conflation of
one aspect of the right wing with
another that doesn't really work either
but i'm trying to address what these
people throw out because that is a
common view at this point
so a question from a viewer why do you
find the argument that music theory is
racist so ridiculous
because it was based on a very thin
premise
a truly brilliant person
looked at mr schenker heinrich
schenker's work
and
found
that i mean this is really the the basis
of it
first of all that all of the people who
get the most praise are white but i
think they're
one reasons for that and two it was a
very long time ago and and we live now
but two the music theory in very obscure
ways has to do with certain elements
being foregrounded and certain elements
being backgrounded or more specifically
elements that are in the background
where if you do certain things you can
make them sound like they're in the
foreground that whole issue of hierarchy
this music theorist claims
is
parallel to views about hierarchy and
i'm going to say that word again
hegemony and racism thank you i swear to
you that's the thesis i tried i read
this work that's the thesis and the
problem is not that somebody wrote
something that
ordinary conditions nobody would pay any
attention to that
it's that music departments across the
country are inviting that person to
speak and share his views and are
discussing his views and i know in
certain cases letting those views affect
their curriculum that's the problem and
make make sure i'm not sure who will be
looking at this i don't think that the
person in question is making any
particular money this has nothing to do
with me being jealous of career success
or anything like that
is influence of that person based on
such a thin premise it's a perfect
absurdity and yet that's being treated
as something significant not only is it
condescending to black brilliance but
it's a waste of time and thinking about
good music of any kind
okay uh another uh viewer uh does the
ongoing discussion on race submerge
class considerations which are central
to many problems
socioeconomics should be held much more
front and center in today's problems and
this is the thing
as if there's only one thing it used to
be that people of a certain type you
call them proto-elects would complain
about the racialization of poverty when
you talk about poverty why is it always
a black woman sitting on the steps with
her kids that was considered the
greatest injustice in the 80s and the
90s well now we don't talk about poverty
that way anymore and the whole
discussion of there being a black
underclass that doesn't bring in that
there's a white underclass who are just
as stuck you know the whole meth
addiction etc jp vance all of that is
very real and it's very talked about
it's about class these days but now
that's wrong you can't talk about class
because you're ignoring that a
meth-addicted person with only half of
their teeth who can't take care of their
kids and will never make a real living
again and is living in a shack somewhere
in a distant place and has no prospects
for the future has white privilege
that's today's discussion and that's
become especially especially important
for many people since about june 2020
that's not a human discussion that is an
exercise that's that's kabuki and it's
obvious that a more rational america at
this point we'll be moving towards
thinking there are black people who need
help they're white people who need the
same help being black now and middle
class is normal and even default you
have to admit you have to polish the
crown we even earned one but no we're
not allowed because we're supposed to
think of
blackness and racism as the eternal root
that rends our nation
i sincerely believe that that view today
is more performance
than pragmatic
reality and you know if it makes me a
white supremacist to call that out i
guess i am one but i think then we need
to redefine what we mean by white
supremacy because frankly the poor
white person who i just described is not
supreme there's nothing supreme about
that and to master the mental exercise
of supposing that somebody like that is
privileged just because they're not
brown is an absurdity it's a waste of
time we're only alive for about 80 years
and we have things to do it's time to
stop those mind games and get down to
really real social justice which and you
know for many people this is a horrible
thing to think social justice should
apply to some white people too it's
always been like that in this country
um
i have a question about
perceptions so pew research does these
polls where they ask people about racism
globally and they looked at they talked
to people from countries and people in
singapore spain japan italy france the
uk they all thought the united states
was more racist in their own countries
uh piece also found that
more black college students experience
racism say they do than than high school
students
and
younger people are more likely to see
discrimination than older people
can you talk about that
do you mean that older people are more
likely to see it than younger
no they're less likely to say they see
it than younger people
are you old older okay yeah i think that
it's obvious that there's an extent to
which education part of a modern
education is that you're educated into
understanding the nature of oppression
which is important but that it can also
teach a black person that they are
suffering
more than for example their ancestors
and by ancestors i mean say grandparents
ancestors they know
would say
that they were and so i'm particularly
interested in that a college student is
more likely to say they experience
racism than a 14 or a 15 year old and
you think to yourself are you really
experiencing more because you're 20 many
people would say that you would
experience it more when you were 14 when
people were less trained to be polite
and so it shows you that there is a slip
between and this is hard there's a slit
between what people will attest and what
the reality is and it's not that
somebody's doing that for malevolent
reasons but nevertheless there's a
certain coaching that i think a lot of
black people undergo not consciously but
we have to watch out for that and for a
white person to call that out takes a
certain amount of bravery and i know
that most white people wouldn't be up
for it and i understand why but that
reality is there and it's as for other
people in other countries
all i can say is that if what they mean
is that they saw the footage of george
floyd being killed i'm sorry but that's
not a metric of whether this country is
more racist than their country we'd have
to look at more than that and i'm sorry
but honestly that is what many
foreigners are led to think they're
shown videos of certain truly disgusting
incidents with the police and they
assume that that is something that
happens all over the country all the
time only to black people when actually
those things happen more to white people
that's a whole other thing or it used to
be that the same kind of european or
japanese person would be shown film of
black ghettos and they would think well
the only reason for that must be that
black people are not liked and therefore
america is a more racist country than
and you know in many cases the country
in question has a kind of racism that's
endemic and more naked than anything
that ever happens here so we have to be
careful about that these days the
measure of america's racism is thought
to be what happened to one man in the
spring of 2020 captured on tragically
clear video
okay
i i'm glad the world is seeing that but
you can't base junior sociology on that
one thing japan is less racist than the
united states i beg to differ
frankly but the george floyd video is
hideous
yeah yeah i understand that i mean in in
america becomes more multi-racial every
year there are more children
born into not not just white families or
black families multiracial families
asians latinos how
how is that affecting how people are
looking at these issues
of wokeness
well you know if you think about the
general trajectory of things
we're at a point where i would say that
that's based on the schematic fiction
that they're white people
and black people and some latinos
scattered in there and what are we gonna
do about these asians and some people
seem to be from india that's the
discussion
that's not gonna make any sense after
about another generation you can just
look at little people now and if you ask
whether i'm thinking about my own kids
whose mother is white the answer is yes
it's going to get to the point where
there are so many people of age who are
mutts where the whole issue of them
having to own that they're black because
they're one-quarter black or sometimes
even half or you know the mother is tai
and the father is from bosnia
what is the child and the child is just
nothing and i think that that kind of
person frustrates the people who like to
talk about white versus black because
they want to keep it down to these
certain categories they want to
for reasons that make sense to them they
want to foster this constant guilt
the truth is when i discuss the sorts of
issues that i discuss i think to myself
i'm putting an awful lot of energy into
a discussion that's going to just look
like something some people a long time
ago were arguing too much about in 50
years but i can't help being part of my
own time and you know no is racism going
to go away it's probably not will there
be some other form of discrimination
that comes into play i suspect classism
will become sharper in that future world
but
we're becoming mutts more and more it
depends on the neighborhood but there
are plenty of mutts in even for example
distant poor white communities there are
a lot of interracial marriages in that
world now although we don't talk about
it much there are a lot of interracial
marriages in the black ghetto
interesting um i'm i'm going to go to
your linguistic background for a second
here uh
i'll read two sentences and you can
explain the difference banks are less
likely to give loans to black people
black people are less likely to get
loans from a bank
i shouldn't laugh i read that article
too
um i
don't
hear
the difference
that much
but i can respect
that the person supposes that if you put
it as banks are less likely to give
loans to black people it'll make you
think
about what it is about the banks where i
lose that person is that that person
just assumes that the answer is that
banks are racist in some way that the
person sitting behind the desk and
assessing the person for a loan is
partly affected by the fact that the
person has brown skin
if you look into issues like that but
you have to look in and frankly
finance
thanks
it's boring no offense to anybody who's
in that business but the person who
wrote that article thinks that frankly i
think that i'm an armchair linguist
you're not going to look into the
details probably but it's not as simple
as just skin color in those cases so
that person is assuming that banks are
racist
banks are probably a teeny bit racist
redlining banks in 2021
as opposed to 1914 or 1952
have all sorts of reasons for doing
things where it would be hard to
identify bigotry or
discrimination
as the reason i'm not sure that that
person talking about language that way
would be open to a discussion about that
but i see where she's coming from
um
i
looking through your bio uh
some things that i found of interest you
went to simon's rock
i did i went to monument mountain
regional high school in great barrington
also the home of w.e.b du bois by the
way and you've been to the mahay that's
right yes that's correct so
tell me about your education you went to
simon's rock you
in the decisions that you made in your
education you you you speak french i
mean
what are the
why did you take this path to get where
you are academically you have the
specialty in linguistics
tell me about what interested you in it
and and
why you made the choices you did
um i didn't make choices i'm a more
feckless person than most people would
have reason to believe i went to four
different schools i went to simon's rock
for two years most people only went
there for two years back then had no
idea what i wanted to do i got an aaa in
french only because i was good at it and
i didn't know what else
then i got a ba from rutgers i went to
rutgers for no reason at all
my parents were not um
not as connected to getting their kids
into great schools as today's parents
would be parents weren't as into that
then i certainly didn't care i should
have gone to swarthmore but they
wouldn't take me
i could have gone to haverford but we
forgot to we've got to hand in a
financial aid form on time and they were
strict about it rutgers was to fall back
i wound up at rutgers
i met some wonderful people at rutgers
who i still know but i shouldn't have
been there in general it was it was two
years on pause i learned a lot about
ragtime while i was at rutgers and then
i went to nyu because i wanted to live
in new york city for a while and i
wanted to read more books and so i got
basically a night school degree in
american studies just a master's i read
some books i got to read the great
gatsby i got to
read you know i got to read
and see how now i don't even remember
but i got to read all sorts of great
things with aging paperbacks i'm looking
at right now and then i spent a couple
of years just kind of spinning my wheels
and i thought i know
the the least feckless thing i did is
that when i was in my very early 20s i
thought
i know i'm a professor i can feel that
that's what i am
but i don't know what of
and then i thought well i seem to have
this facility with languages and the
only reason i knew that that meant
linguistics was because i was working in
a copy center at nyu to make ends meet
and people would bring in journals and
things to be copied and there was one
person who was a linguist there who
would bring in that's the only reason i
knew what linguistics was
and i thought well i guess maybe i can
do that
that is really the story and so i got a
phd in it because i could fake being
good at it which is really the best that
i did while i was actually getting the
degree and none of this had anything to
do with becoming a race commentator you
would have perplexed me if you had said
to me in 1992 that you're probably going
to be best known for saying contrary
things about race that make people hate
you that is not what i was planning but
i just throughout the 90s i thought
things get better and better for black
people despite rodney king despite this
that and the other thing and i found
that the educated view was that things
had not changed for black people since
1960 and i didn't understand why and
there's a part of me it's partly just
being tidy i couldn't rest with it
i couldn't say these people are crazy
because they weren't i couldn't say
these people were stupid because a lot
of them were smarter than me
but i thought they are not processing
reality why are they exaggerating what
is this
and that is what slowly led
i think it was particularly fueled by
oj
you know it's at the point where we can
say it's painfully clear that the man
murdered two people and yet for many
many years black people of all
educational stripes were pretending not
to see it i just i
didn't get it
and that's what led me to write losing
the race in 2000
[Music]
i had no idea it would become so widely
read i wrote it kind of as therapy i
happened to write quickly and i thought
i'm going to put this out there so
people will know what i think and maybe
some younger black people will see that
i'm not crazy just like shelby steele
taught me that i'm not crazy
and
lo and behold losing the race was a
minor
best seller
and more lo and behold i never stopped
being asked to write editorials i kept
on thinking well i guess i'm having 15
minutes then it became a half hour and
then around 08 i thought you know people
are not going to leave me alone and so
then i settled into it but for me it
really was just i want to be a professor
i like languages i thought i was gonna
write the book on looney tunes and not
the minstrel ones all of them i've seen
850 of the 1000 i love them to pieces
and somehow that didn't happen and so
here i am just just dealing with how
life actually came out but it's all just
been a crap shoot really but
i wouldn't have it any other way
i mean i have to tell you i'm
it's a great book i highly recommend it
uh and i'm curious there it is it is
it's a great book it's a it's it's a
fast read i mean there's there's no
there's no space where it slows down you
just keep moving on i recommend it to
everyone what's your next
book well i want to say folks just
because there was a little
normal crosstalk there what i was saying
there was not it is a great book i said
there it is because i'm always so
impressed to see it with a physical
object i was saying there it is i don't
know if it's a great book um
you know deborah i don't know what the
next book is and people are going to
think i'm just saying this to seem cute
or something but i thought the next book
is not going to be some angry screed you
know it's exhausting representing a book
that never smiles
and so i thought i wanted to be
something fun
and i actually thought
i wonder if i could get it by my agent
to write the book on looney tunes from
1930 to last week because i think they
are high art wouldn't you know that god
damn it somebody just came out with a
book about the looney tunes and so now i
can't i can't do it somebody else wrote
it
and so
jamie weinman damn you and so now i have
to write it about something else and you
know i i don't know i think the next
book is going to be something about
language
and um
that's as far as i've gotten i have no
idea because to be honest i did two
in this calendar year and my brain is
fried so i need a break
so my next book is going to be about you
know what it's going to be about not
race
not race maybe that'll be the title
maybe you can go against the looney
tunes book that already came out
maybe you can have a different a counter
theory on it my looney tunes that's
right yeah
really wrong on looney tunes
anyway
it's a thought
um i think i'm supposed to close this
down now if i'm wrong uh well i guess
it'll be some dead space afterward um
anyway unfortunately that is all all the
time we have for today's program
i want to thank the commonwealth club
for hosting it and i really want to
encourage everyone to purchase a copy of
john mcwhorter's terrific new book woke
racism wherever books are sold uh and
really uh you can you can read it in the
weekend and feel smarter afterward
and i also want to encourage everyone to
become a member of the commonwealth club
visit the commonwealth's club club site
at www.commonwealthclub.org
and learn how to become a member this
program and others like it will be
posted soon on the website site
okay my mouth is done thank you so much
john i really appreciate it i'm deborah
j saunders in this commonwealth club
program is now adjourned
thank you thank you
here's a look at some publishing
industry news the children's book
publisher scholastic home of the harry
potter series and worth an estimated 1.2